THE PRESIDENT IS NOT DOING MY
HOUR LIKE TUCKER.
WE BEGIN WITH OUR OPENING
MONOLOGUE.
THE RALLY YOU SAW ON FOX JUST
ENDED.
YOU WOULD NOT KNOW IT IF YOU
WERE WATCHING THE MAINSTREAM
MEDIA.
CNN BARELY COVERED IT.
AND CONSPIRACY TV MSNBC ACTED
LIKE IT WAS NOT HAPPENING.
WE BROUGHT YOU THE RALLY
INCLUDING WHEN THE PRESIDENT
TOOK DEMOCRATS AND THE
MAINSTREAM MEDIA TO TASK OVER
THE TOPIC OF IMMIGRATION.
ONE REASON THE MEDIA DID NOT
COVER IT THEY WOULD BE CALLED
OUT FOR ALL OF THEIR LIES AND
THE FACT THEY ARE MISSING THE
BIGGEST STORY IN AMERICAN
HISTORY.
>> DEMOCRATS DON'T CARE ABOUT
THE IMPACT OF UNCONTROLLED
MIGRATION ON YOUR COMMUNITIES,
SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS.
YOUR JOBS OR YOUR SAFETY.
DEMOCRATS PULL ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BEFORE THEY PUT
AMERICAN CITIZENS.
WE ALREADY STARTED THE WALL.
WE HAVE 1.6 MILLION.
THE WALL HAS BEEN STARTED.
BARKS IT'S TOUGH.
THEY WANT TO OBSTRUCT AND MAKE
SURE IT DOESN'T HAPPEN.
IT'S HAPPENING.
>> Sean: FOR DAYS.
THE DESTROY TRUMP MEDIA AND
THEIR FRIENDS IN THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY HAVE BEEN IN AN INSANE
MELTDOWN THAT CHILDREN WERE
SEPARATED FROM PARENTS AT THE
BORDER EVER BEING DETAINED FROM
CROSSING THE BORDER ILLEGALLY.
I SAID NUMEROUS TIMES:
NO ONE EVER WANTS TO SEE A KID
SEPARATED FROM THEIR PARENTS.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THAT ALL
WEEK.
THE PRESIDENT ADDRESSED THIS
IMPORTANT ISSUE AND SIGNED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER UNDOING THEIR
DAMAGE AND ENSURING THAT ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS FAMILIES WOULD BE
KEPT INTACT.
IT WAS NOT HIS LAW.
HE DID NOT PASS IT.
CONGRESS DID.
ANOTHER PRESIDENT SIGNED IT, BUT
HE FIXED IT.
>> BORDER SECURITY WILL BE EQUAL
IF NOT GREATER THAN PREVIOUSLY,
BUT WE WILL KEEP THE FAMILIES
TOGETHER.
I DIDN'T LIKE THE SIGHT OF
FAMILIES BEING SEPARATED.
WE ARE WORKING HARD ON
IMMIGRATION.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR 60 YEARS!
60 YEARS, NOBODY HAS TAKEN CARE
OF IT.
NOBODY HAD THE POLITICAL COURAGE
TO TAKE CARE OF IT.
WE ARE GOING TO TAKE CARE OF IT.
>> Sean: TODAY THE PRESIDENT
UNDID THE DAMAGE CONGRESS
MANDATED AND A PREVIOUS
PRESIDENT SIGNED.
THIS ORDER FILLS A VOID VACATED
BY CONGRESS WHICH DROPPED THE
BALL WITH ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND
LEGAL IMMIGRATIONS.
NOW IT'S TIME FOR THE LAZY
CONGRESS TO STEP UP AND DO THEIR
JOB.
THAT'S A PERMANENT SOLUTION.
FIX OUR BROKEN IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
IF WE ARE GOING TO DO IT, DO IT
RIGHT.
ANY BILL NEEDS TO POINT OUT WHAT
THE PRESIDENT LAID OUT.
GOING BACK TO A STATE OF THE
UNION ADDRESS.
SECURE THE BORDER AND BUILD THE
WALL.
THE PROBLEM IS SOLVED
COMPLETELY.
IT MUST BE COMPLETELY FUNDED AND
CONSTRUCTED AND THE MONEY --
WELL, I DON'T TRUST THESE GUYS.
GET IT UP FRONT OR NO DEAL.
ALL OF THE LOOPHOLES HAVE TO BE
CLOSED USED BY CRIMINALS AND
TERRORISTS TO ENTER THIS
COUNTRY.
THAT INCLUDE CHAIN MIGRATION AND
THEN AND ONLY THEN THE DEMOCRATS
WILL WIN SOMETHING TOO.
THEY WILL GET THEIR CONCESSIONS
ON DACA AND THE ISSUE OF CHILD
AND PARENT SEPARATION WILL END
FOREVER.
SOMETHING WE ALL SAY WE WANT.
THE WALL, THE LOTTO SYSTEM.
THE END OF CATCH AND RELEASE.
THEY CAN'T BE TALKING POINTS.
CONGRESS WE ARE ON TO YOU.
WE ARE WATCHING YOU.
WE KNOW YOU OFTEN LIE IN YOUR
TALKING POINTS AND SAY ONE THING
AND IT NEVER MATCHES THE FINE
PRINT OF THE BILL.
DON'T PLAY THESE SWAMP GAMES.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE HIP TO
YOUR LIES.
EVERYTHING WE ARE TALKING ABOUT
NEEDS TO BE STRAIGHTFORWARD AND
FULLY LEGISLATED AND ENACTED
BEFORE A DACA COMPROMISE.
WITHOUT A WALL, THE PROBLEMS AT
THE WALL WILL NEVER GO AWAY.
EVER!
SADLY, WE HAVE TO SEE ALL OF
THIS THROUGH THE MID-TERM
ELECTIONS.
EVERYTHING ON THE FAKE NEWS
NETWORKS IS ABOUT 2018.
INSTEAD OF PASSING LEGISLATION
TO FIX THE IMMIGRATION PROBLEM,
YOU HAVE MANY DEMOCRATS THEY
WOULD RATHER USE THIS ISSUE TO
BELINE THEIR POLITICAL OPPONENTS
THAT FITS INTO THEIR BRAND OF
IDENTITY POLITICS.
THEY WANT THE AMERICAN PEOPLE TO
BELIEVE THAT REPUBLICANS ARE
RACIST, AND MISOGYNY AND THEY
WANT TO KILL YOUR CHILDREN AND
PUSH YOUR GRANDMOTHER OVER A
CLIFF.
YOU HEAR THOSE LIES EVERY 2 AND
4 YEARS.
THE 4 THINGS THAT WILL HAPPEN.
YOU LET DEMOCRATS WIN THIS
ELECTION, THIS MID-TERM, AND
GUESS PAL HAPPEN?
THIS IS THEIR AGENDA, NUMBER 1,
THEY WANT TO IMPEACH THE
PRESIDENT.
THEY TOLD EVERY DEMOCRAT STOP
MAXINE WATERS FROM SAYING
IMPEACH.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
THEY WANT TO KEEP OBAMACARE.
AND JUST LIKE NANCY PELOSI SAID,
THEY WANT TO ROLL BACK THE TAX
CUTS AND STEAL THOSE CRUMBS BACK
THAT THE PRESIDENT GAVE YOU IN
THE TAX CUTS BILL.
EARLIER TODAY THE PRESIDENT
EXPOSED THE DEMOCRATS AND THE
MEDIA'S HYPOCRISY.
LOOK AT THE VIDEO THE PRESIDENT
TWEETED.
THIS IS PRICELESS.
FAKE A LOOK.
>> ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTSION IS
WRONG.
>> ALL AMERICANS, NOT ONLY IN
THE STATES HEAVILY EFFECTED ARE
DISTURBED BY THE LARGE NUMBERS
OF ILLEGAL ALIENS ENTERING OUR
COUNTRY.
>> WE HAVE TO SEND A CLEAR
MESSAGE.
JUST BECAUSE YOUR CHILD GETS
ACROSS THE BORDER, THAT DOESN'T
MEAN THE CHILD GETS TO STAY.
>> THE PRESIDENT AND THE
DEMOCRATS AND THE MEDIA ARE
PLAYING POLITICS.
THIS PRESIDENT VOWED TO FIX THE
IMMIGRATION CRISIS IN IN
COUNTRY.
THAT DID NOT STOP YOUR MEDIA
FROM GOING OFF THE RAILS INSANE.
LISTEN TO A CLIP.
>> NBC NEWS REPORT LESTER HOLT
INTERVIEWING A BORDER PATROL
CHIEF.
>> DO YOU FEEL LIKE THE BAD GUY
YOU?
ARE THE INSTRUMENT OF A POLICY
THAT IS VERY CONTROVERSIAL RIGHT
NOW?
>> Sean: A BAD GUY.
LESTER, GET OUT OF THE STEWED.
-- STUDIO.
I HAVE BEEN IN THE BORDER AND IN
THE DRUG WAREHOUSES WHEN THEY
ARRESTED GANG MEMBER.
FLOOR TO CEILING LAID AT THE
ALTAR OF GOING TO OUR KIDS.
LESTER, NO WONDER YOU ARE NOT
NUMBER 1 IN NEWS ANYMORE.
RISKING HIS LIFE?
YES, HE IS SAVING OUR KIDS FROM
DRUGS AND THOSE PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BAD INTENTIONS AT THE BORDER.
IT GETS SO MUCH WORSE.
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT A FULL-ON
PSYCHOTIC MELTDOWN.
HOLOCAUST AND SLAVERY
COMPARISONS.
CHECK OUT THIS INSANITY.
>> DONALD TRUMP IS PURE EVIL.
YOU PLAY THE TAPES IN THE
CENTERS.
IT'S HORRIFIC.
THAT HASN'T HAPPENED IN THIS
COUNTRY SINCE SLAVERY.
IT HASN'T HAPPENED SINCE THE
TIME OF THE NAZI AND DONALD
TRUMP IS RIGHT THERE WITH THEM.
>> THIS IS AS IF GEORGE WALLACE
WON IN 1968.
THIS IS A RETURN TO THE MOST
DISTURBING ELEMENT OF WHITE
SEPREMACY.
>> THEY CREATED CRIMINALS.
THAT'S WHAT HAPPENED.
HE SAID TO ME, THE NAZIS HAD IT
CORRECT.
THEY DECLARED US AN INLEGAL
PEOPLE.
THAT'S HOW IT BEGAN.
>> I DON'T WANT LITTLE CHILDREN
RIPPED FROM THEIR PARENT'S ARMS.
I DON'T WANT THEM MARCHED OFF TO
SHOWERS.
>> YOU LOOK AT THIS
HISTORICALLY, THE SEPARATION OF
FAMILIES SPEAKS TO A LEVEL OF
INHUMANITY.
>> Sean: LIBERAL JOE THINKS HE
IS A CONSERVATIVE.
IF YOU CAN BELIEVE TTHE REACTION
FROM SOME THE LEFT WAS SO MUCH
WORSE.
I HAVE KIDS AT HOME AND I HATE
SAYING TURN OFF THE CHANNEL OR
BE CAREFUL.
THIS IS NOT SUITABLE FEBRUARY
KIDS.
-- FOR KIDS.
ACTOR PETER FONDA TWEETED ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP'S NIELSEN:
HE CONTINUED TO RANT.
HE TURN HIS SICK, VICIOUS RAGE
TO A 12-YEAR-OLD KID.
THE PRESIDENT AND MELANIA TRUMP
BARRON:
OKAY.
DISGUSTING.
THE FIRST LADY HAS EVERY RIGHT
TO PROTECT HER CHILD.
MAKING TERRORISTS THREATS
AGAINST THE FIRST LADY IS
ILLEGAL.
SHE CONTACTED THE SECRET SERVICE
AFTER THAT TWEET.
PETER FOND SOBERED UP AND
DELETED THE TWEET AND SAID HE
WENT TOO FAR.
YOU COULD BE ARRESTED FOR THOSE
WORDS AND YOU SHOULD BE.
THE BIG QUESTION OF THE DAY?
WHY IS NANCY PELOSI?
WHERE IS ELIZABETH WARREN?
THE CHAMPION OF WOMEN HILLARY
CLINTON?
THE OUTRAGE FROM THE
COMPASSIONATE LEFT?
FONDA'S COMMENTS WERE SICK AND
THIS IS THE INSANITY COMING FROM
AMERICA'S LEFT.
THERE IS A LOT MORE.
LOOK AT OCCUPY WALL STREET
PROMOTING THE MURDERING OF ICE
AGENTS, PUBLISHING A LIST OF ICE
AGENT'S PERSONAL INFORMATION.
THEY ARE GOING TO GET SOMEONE
KILLED.
AND THEN THIS HAPPENED.
NIELSEN IS RUN OUT OF A
RESTAURANT LAST NIGHT BY A GROUP
OF LEFTIST PROTESTORS.
WE HAVE THE VIDEO.
WATCH THIS LEFT WING INSTANITY.
>> [SHOUTING]
>> DEPORTATION OF 10,000
CHILDREN SEPARATED FROM THEIR
CHILDREN.
>> [BOOING]
>> YOU ARE DEPORTING TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHO COME
HERE SEEKING ASYLUM IN THE
UNITED STATES.
>> END THE SEPARATION.
>> [SHOUTING]
>> HOMELAND SECURITY SECRETARY
IS IN A MEXICAN RESTAURANT.
THE [BLEEP] GALL!
SHAME ON YOU.
SHAME, SHAME, SHAME!
>> Sean: HILLARY CLINTON AND
NANCY PELOSI AND ELIZABETH
WARREN WHERE ARE YOU?
WHERE IS THE ME TOO MOVEMENT.
WHILE THE LEFT MEDIA BLOWS UP
OVER THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
BORDER TACTICS, AND THEY ARE
OBEYING THE LAW, THEY WERE VERY
QUIET WHEN OBAMA WAS THEIR
PRESIDENT.
THE IMAGES WE ARE ABOUT TO SHOW
YOU.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS.
CHILDREN IN CAGES.
SLEEPING IN CAGES.
WITHOUT THEIR PARENTS BEING
THERE AT ALL.
MANY SEPARATED FROM THEIR
PARENTS.
THESE IMAGES THEY WERE NOT TAKEN
AFTER DONALD TRUMP WAS SPARINE
INTO OFFICE.
-- SWORN INTO OFFICE.
THIS WAS UNDER BARACK OBAMA.
THOSE PICTURES ARE FROM THE
OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
THIS IS HOW THEY DETAINED
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND CHILDREN.
ONE SUCH OBAMA ERA POLICY
DETAINED MINORS WITHOUT THEIR
PARENTS 4 MONTHS BEFORE
RELEASING THEM BACK TO THEIR
HOME COUNTRY.
PRESIDENT OBAMA PROSECUTED HALF
A MILLION ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS AND
NOT DONALD TRUMP.
IT WAS OBAMA WHO SAID HE WAS
MERELY ENFORCING THE LAWS THAT
HE COULD NOT CHANGE EVEN IF THEY
CREATED GREAT DAMAGE.
REMEMBER?
HE SAID ALL OF THIS.
>> THERE ARE THOSE IN THE
IMMIGRANTS RIGHTS COMMUNITY WHO
HAVE ARGUED, PASSIONATELY, THAT
WE SHOULD SIMPLY PROVIDE THOSE
WHO ARE HERE ILLEGALLY OR IGNORE
THE LAOS THE BOOKS.
I BELIEVE SUCH AN APPROACH IS
UNWISE AND UNFAIR.
WHEN I TALKED TO IMMIGRATION
ADVOCATES.
THEY WISH I THINK BYPASS
CONGRESS AND CHANGE THE LAW
MYSELF.
THAT'S NOT HOW DEMOCRACY WORKS.
THE IDEA OF DOING THINGS ON MY
OWN IS TEMPTING.
I PROMISE YOU.
WANT JUST ON IMMIGRATION REFORM.
BUT THAT'S NOT HOW OUR SYSTEM
WORKS.
I AM THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
I AM NOT THE EMPEROR OF THE
UNITED STATES.
MY JOB IS TO EXECUTE LAWS THAT
ARE PASSED.
>> Sean: MY JOB IS TO EXECUTE
LAWS THAT ARE PASSED.
WHAT DONALD TRUMP SIGNED TODAY
IT WILL LAST 5 MINUTES IN A
COURTROOM BEFORE IT'S THROWN OUT
BUT IT GIVES CONGRESS TIME TO DO
THEIR JOB.
FIRST SOMETHING ELSE TO BRING
YOU THAT THE LEFT IS BARELY
TOUCHING.
ONE OF THE BIGGEST STORIES OF
OUR LIFETIME.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL REPORT
VINDICATING THE PRESIDENT'S
DECISION TO FIRE JAMES COMEY AND
THE IG REPORT CORROBORATING
EVERYTHING WE HAVE TOLD YOU THAT
THE REST OF THE MEDIA NEVER
TALKED ABOUT.
A 2-TIERED JUSTICE SYSTEM AND A
BIAS AND AN ATTEMPT TO CREATE A
SOFT COUP IN AMERICA AND DESTROY
ONE CANDIDATE.
THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA COULD CARE
LESS.
ON MONDAY CBS IGNORED THE IG
REPORT.
AFTER 2 DAYS OF DAMNING FROM
MICHAEL HOROWITZ ABOUT PETER
STRZOK, YESTERDAY THE FRIENDS AT
ABC SO-CALLED NEWS.
GEORGE STEPHANOPOULOS'S PLACE,
THEY AVOIDED COVERING STRZOK AT
ALL.
THE GUY AT THE CENTER OF THE
BIGGEST CORRUPTION SCANDAL IN
AMERICAN HISTORY.
WE KNOW ONE OF THE MOST CENTRAL
FIGURES WAS THE ANTI-TRUMP FBI
AGENT PETER STRZOK.
THEY DOUBT IF HE WILL TESTIFY.
WE SHOWED YOU A DETAILED
TIMELINE LAST NIGHT ON PETER
STRZOK AND HIS GIRLFRIEND LISA
PAGE.
STRZOK PROTECTED HILLARY FROM
KNOWN FELONIES.
REMEMBER STRZOK WAS THE LEAD
AGENT IN HER CASE.
THAT'S UNDER INVESTIGATION AND
THEN TAPPED FOR THE LEAD ROLE IN
THE FBI'S TRUMP-RUSSIAN
INVESTIGATION RENDERING
ILLEGITIMATE MUELLER'S
INVESTIGATION.
HE CLEARED HILLARY WHO COMMITTED
ONE FELONY AFTER ANOTHER AND
WORKED AGAINST DONALD TRUMP AND
TRIED TO DESTROY HIM.
THAT WAS ALL IN THE CONTEXT OF A
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
THAT SOUNDS LIKE A BIG DEAL TO
ME IN A LOT OF DIFFERENT WAYS.
AS HE IS TRYING TO PROTECT
HILLARY CLINTON, ISN'T IT
INTERESTING THAT IT DIDN'T WORK
OUT.
WE SCROLL FORWARD.
STRZOK WAS THE LEAD AGENT IN
HILLARY'S SERVER INVESTIGATION.
NOBODY IN THE MEDIA TELLS YOU
THIS.
HE CLEARS ONE PERSON.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
IN THE CONTEXT OF A PRESIDENTIAL
ELECTION.
TARGETING DONALD TRUMP WHO
BECOMES PRESIDENT.
ALL RIGHT, AS WE MOVE ON.
HE WILL BE CALLED TO TESTIFY
BEFORE CONGRESS AND THE HOUSE
JUDICIARY CHAIRMAN IS READY TO
ISSUE A SUBPOENA.
MY PREDICTION HE AIN'T GOING TO
TALK.
HE WILL JOIN US IN A FEW
MINUTES.
AND WE KNOW STRZOK IS THE TIP OF
THE FBI HIGH LEVEL CORRUPTION.
THE
TH
THE IG REFERRED 5 FOR PENDING
ACTION.
THIS IS BEGINING TO COLLAPSE.
PEOPLE WILL GO TO JAIL OVER
THIS.
WE ARE LEARNING ANOTHER WRINKLE
IN THE DEEP STATE SURROUNDING
CHRISTOPHER STEELE.
THE FOREIGN SPY WHOM THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN PAID FOR TO PRODUCE
PHONEY RUSSIAN LIES AGAINST
TRUMP, STEELE, HE WAS WELCOMED
AT OBAMA'S STATE DEPARTMENT JUST
DAYS BEFORE THE 2016 ELECTION
WHERE HE ALLEGEDLY BRIEFED
OFFICIALS.
WHAT DID JOHN KERRY AND OBAMA
KNOW?
WHAT DID THEY DO WITH THIS
PHONEY INFORMATION?
WHEN IS THE MEDIA GOING TO START
TALKING ABOUT THIS?
WHAT IS THE NEXT SHOE TO DROP IN
ALL OF THIS?
WE HAVE MORE TO COME IN THE